invité andré bergeron force ouvrière sur
le front politique et syndical francs la
baisse stopper valéry giscard d'estaing
raymond barre halte par tous les moyens
techniques à la dépréciation de la
monnaie
enlèvement du juge d'aix est un major de
crise à lyon
la voiture des ravisseurs retrouver mais
encore peu d'un 10 barbara le grand
retour un entretien exclusif avec george
v go
messieurs bonsoir je sais bien que les
lyonnais n'aime pas trop qu'on se
hasarde à qualifier leur bonne ville
mais ne voulait pas aux journalistes
lyon est tout de même la seule ville de
france où l'on tue de sang froid un
magistrat c'était il ya deux ans et demi
l'assassinât du juge renaud c'est aussi
depuis hier soir la seule ville de
france où l'on enlève un juge en pleine
rue en effet ce qui s'est passé dans le
quartier de la croix rousse pas très
loin du domicile de monsieur noël d'aix
cet homme que vous voyez derrière moi
président de chambre au tribunal de
grande instance a lyon un homme qui
n'avait pas eu ces derniers temps à
traiter d' affaire de grand banditisme
alors bien sûr on se pose des questions
sur cette impunité des truands à lyon et
le mystère la justice a décidé de mettre
sur pied là-bas un véritable état-major
de crise pour essayer de retrouver les
ravisseurs de monsieur noël text 24
heures après cet enlèvement
on ne connaît toujours pas les mobiles
des ravisseurs qui apparemment ne se
sont pas encore manifestés on pense bien
sûr à une vengeance un règlement de
comptes comme pour l'assassinât du juge
renaud en 1975
on pense à une vengeance aussi deux
d'anciens condamnés ou peut être une
monnaie d'échangé en vue de demander la
libération d'un ou de plusieurs détenus
bref on reste ce soir à lyon dans le
domaine des hypothèses
une chose est certaine les trois hommes
masqués qui ont enlevé le juge dans ce
paisible quartier de la croix rousse
connaissait parfaitement ses habitudes
il savait que noël d'aix célibataire
vivait seul et qu'il faisait toujours
ses courses au même endroit dans son
quartier
avant de rentrer chez lui hier soir vers
19h15 ses ravisseurs agissant
apparemment sans armes se sont jetés sur
lui elles l'ont poussée de force vers
une voiture dans laquelle attendait un
complice
un témoin raconte j'ai entendu crier au
secours au secours il s'est précipité
derrière la fenêtre j'ai vu deux hommes
en cagoule qui étaient dans la voiture
sa perceuse et quel tissu de la tête et
un autre cas cool quoi qui tirait sur un
homme qui hurlait qu'était caractère me
suis précipité sur téléphone quand je
suis revenue la voiture et qui est parti
vous alors que la police j'ai appelé la
police
entre temps mon voisin est venu et m'a
dit qu'il avait relevé numéro chez
d'année numéro vous connaissiez le juge
d'aix non je vois pas non c'est pas
physionomie la seule preuve matérielle
que possède pour l'instant les
enquêteurs dans cette affaire et cette
voiture dans laquelle le juge a été
enlevé une renault 12 volé retrouvé ce
matin dans la zone au nord de lyon
des hommes grenouilles ont fouillé
aujourd'hui le fleuve ils n'ont rien
trouvé
pour quel mobile à temps levées noël
d'aix et bien sûr ce que l'état-major de
crise installée à lyon sur ordre du
ministre de la justice vingt ses pensées
d'établir pas de problème particulier
dans la vie professionnelle du magistrat
toutefois un dossier traité par noël
d'aix juge d'instruction avant sa
nomination le 1er février comme premier
juge inquiète les enquêteurs celui
concernant la tacc le 5 décembre dernier
de la femme d'un avocat général de lyon
par deux inconnus
madame nicole blanc jouvent avait été
revu et de coûts ainsi que sa femme de
ménage
c'est peut être à partir de ce dossier
que va s'orienter pour l'instant
l'enquète je crois aussi qu'il faut en
profiter pour faire le point ce soir sur
l'enlèvement du baron empain
nous en parlons peu parce que nous
n'avons que très peu d'informations
parce que la famille ne souhaite pas que
des informations disant hasardeuse
puisse mettre en danger la vie du bar un
indice toutefois que nous pouvons porter
à votre connaissance
une nouvelle photo encore faut-il
replacer l'information dans son juste
contexte remonte en lui disant
immédiatement qu'il n'y a pas eu d'envoi
ces jours ci d'une nouvelle photo du
groupe
en réalité il y a une dizaine de jours
les ravisseurs en bien en vrille et deux
séries de photos faites à un ou deux
jours d'intervalle et déposé à la
consigne automatique d'une grande gare
parisienne
et c'est sur l'une de ses photos
justement des polaroïds couleurs que
l'on voit le baron les traits tirés le
visage mangé par la barbe et montrant sa
main ensanglantée amputé d'une phalange
à l'auriculaire gauche
répétons le cette photo a été prise avec
la première et peut-être avec d'autres
il ya une dizaine de jours et depuis
plus rien une photo assez
impressionnante alors plus rien
également ci concerne les contacts entre
la famille et les ravisseurs
oui là aussi plus rien mais depuis une
semaine seulement très précisément
depuis le lundi 30 janvier
vous savez que la semaine précédant ce
lundi 30 janvier des contacts avaient
été noués entre les ravisseurs et la
famille probablement
les contacts téléphoniques et là on a
buté sur des chiffres les ravisseurs
exigent une rançon de 80 millions de
francs 8 milliards de centimes la
famille proposant de réunir trois
milliards de centimes
et à ce propos on croit savoir que la
banque de france a reçu des ordres très
strictes pour ne payer aucune rançon
tout ceci bien entendu au conditionnel
car comme vous l'imaginez il est très
difficile d'avoir des informations
auprès des policiers surtout surtout
depuis que l' affaire est entre les
mains de la justice avec la désignation
d'un vil et l'ouverture d'une
information judiciaire
un mot enfin pour signaler que
contrairement à certaines informations
les barrages policiers n'ont pas été
levées comme l'exigeaient les ravisseurs
le ministère de l'intérieur que j'ai eu
tout à l'heure avant de descendre dans
ses studios me l'a confirmé
le dispositif policier le mal que celui
de la semaine dernière simplement il est
moins visible
j'ajoute à cette rubrique à un crime
particulièrement odieux qui fait penser
un peu à ce qui s'est passé à sucy en
brie le mois dernier des voleurs se sont
introduits hier matin à méricourt près
de lens dans le domicile d'un
entrepreneur de bâtiment
ils ont tué les pousses de
l'entrepreneur et en noyer sa petite
fille âgée de 5 ans c'est vraiment
écoeurant
deux suspects ont été interpellés mais
il nie toujours la santé du franc
maintenant il a repris du tonus
aujourd'hui il s'est redressé légèrement
et la bourse ait remonté le brillant
république lui même est intervenu pour
essayer de stopper la baisse du franc
après la semaine noire du début février
concernant la situation du front nous
n'avons pas parlé avec le chancelier
mais puisque j'ai devant moi des
représentants des grands moyens
d'informations je vous indique que j'ai
donné au premier ministre la directive
de mettre en oeuvre tous les moyens
techniques nécessaires pour s'opposer à
la dépréciation du franc
ou alors nous reparlerons tout à l'heure
des entretiens franco allemands mais
raymond barre qui entame guy entamé
aujourd'hui son premier déplacement en
province
le premier sa campagne et orale à
travers la france à montbard aussitôt
pris le relais du président république
et en a profité pour stigmatiser au
havre l'attitude de ceux qui attaquent
le front l'écoutant nous savions bien
que la période électorale serait une
période difficile mais la leçon est
maintenant donné et nous retrouver
la stabilité de notre monnaie nous
retrouvons les raisons de confiance en
l'avenir
le jour où les français et tous ceux qui
à l'étranger travaillent qu'avec les
français auront acquis la certitude que
l' aventure économique est épargné à ce
pays
oui le havre était la première étape du
voyage normand du premier ministre il a
tenu un meeting dans un hangar au milieu
de petits avions vous savez que là bas
la municipalité communiste
il a donc pas vraiment accueilli raymond
barre en fanfare deuxième étape une
petite localité montville ou raymond
barre a été accueilli par des une
centaine de jeunes gens qui scandaient
des slogans hostiles à la majorité et
puis troisième étape
rouen où le premier ministre doit
prononcer un autre discours
dans quelques minutes et daniel brême
est déjà sur place oui j'ai du mal à
vous autant en choisissant ce parcours
on la première étape de son tour de
france qui va le mener dans une douzaine
de régions
monsieur bart ouvry les le leader de la
majorité tout entière au dessus des
tendances et des partis en effet il a
rendu visite successivement au havre rpr
à menville un réformateur de monsieur le
jeune et à rouen ce sera un cds il en
sera ainsi au fil des jours une seule
nécessité soutenir le président de la
république et les objectifs d'action de
blois autre symbole
il est au dessus de mon épaule vous le
voyez sans doute en ce moment c'est
celui qui figure au dessus de l'estrade
et qui est le sigle qui a été choisi par
monsieur var c'est un arbre signe de vie
de solidité et de sérieux dans son
discours qu'il n'est pas écrit le
premier ministre doit insister sur le
fait que les objectifs de loi représente
pour les france et l'espoir
face au programme commun qui est pour
lui symbole d'illusions et de déception
des milliers de personnes ont déjà
envahi la salle on attend d'ici très peu
de temps
monsieur bart et je vous donne
rendez-vous après son discours politique
ce n'est pas encore une série de petites
phrases je reconnais que les
journalistes en sont un petit peu trop
friand peut-être mais comment résister
par exemple au désir de vous faire
écouter ce que jacques chirac hier soir
à brest a dit de genre l'accent à
travers écoutez le sait très court mais
c'est drôle que ce pays a connu pendant
la gestion du général de gaulle de
georges pompidou et de ceux qui l'ont
soutenu qui les ont soutenus les
changements les plus considérables les
plus substantielles de son histoire
contemporaine et que nous n'avons donc
strictement aucune leçon à recevoir de
ceux qui parlent du changement comme les
vieillards par des petites filles
il est dit jacques chirac il sera demain
l'invité des gens perdent gabach et
d'alain duhamel pour cartes sur table
donc à 20h30 demain mercredi
hier soir toujours sur notre chaîne un
débat que vous avez peut-être pu voir
entre christian bonnet gars sont de
faire un débat au cours duquel gaston
defferre a renvoyé au chef de l'état la
responsabilité de choisir ou non
des ministres communistes
si c'est françois mitterrand comme je
l'espère au programme et non un jour à
marseille
oui pourquoi me cacherais opposera des
noms au président de la république est
le président de la république dira oui
ou en fusera c'est à ce moment là que
dialogue s'engage entre le premier
ministre et le président de la
république
il y aura donc une responsabilité du
président de la république qui signera
le décret de nomination des ministres
cette responsabilité que vous voulez
faire peser sur les épaules ce soir je
m'affole j'accepterai si les
circonstances politiques le permettait
elle ne pèse pas sur mes épaules d'abord
parce que les élections n'ont pas lieu
n'ont pas eu lieu
deuxièmement parce que je ne suis pas le
dire la gauche troisièmement parce que
la constitution prévoit que c'est sur
proposition du premier ministre que
c'est le président l'a vu mais qui
signent alors allez demander à votre ami
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing
s'il acceptera de nommer des ministres
communistes et à quel poste et on ne
peut pas dire que ce soit un moment là
la position du parti communiste
et pour en finir avec cette querelle pc
ps sachez que le maire socialiste de
charleville mézières a retiré leurs
délégations à 3 mais si l'adjoint
communiste avec nous maintenant sur ce
plateau andré bergeron sa tête un
général de force ouvrière andré vacheron
bonjour quel que soit votre désir vous
allez bien être obligé vous force
ouvrière de vous engager dans cette
bataille électorale la cgt la cfdt fo
bien
alors quel bon choix pour force ouvrière
mais justement nous ne voulons pas nous
engager
je ne vois pas en vertu de quelle morale
de quel principe nous aurions la
prétention de prendre nos adhérents par
la main pour les mener aux urnes mais
les deux centrales concurrence le font
bien
mais écoutez chacun fait ce qu'il veut
mais voyons dans force ouvrière il y a
des adhérents qui viennent des milieux
anarchistes trotskiste
radicaux-socialistes indépendant
gaulliste et cetera faut pas s'étonner
de ça nous l'avons voulu nous avons
proclamé que les syndicats et fo était
ouvert à tous les salariés quel que soit
leurs conceptions politiques
philosophiques ou religieuses alors nous
nous engageons pas pour trois raisons la
première parce que nous sommes
composites comme je viens de le dire
deuxièmement parce que nos statuts nous
l'interdisent
et troisièmement parce que nous portons
en nous une certaine conception du rôle
respectif des partis et des syndicats
dans la société démocratique
les parties ont vocation à la direction
de l'état le mouvement syndical n'a pas
cette vocation
quel que soit le gouvernement de demain
quel que soit le régime
il devra défendre les intérêts matériels
et moraux de la classe ouvrière
alors je signale quand même que pour la
fédération cfdt des ptt vous avez choisi
votre camp c'est le camp de la droite
réactionnaire et musclé c'est là la cfdt
fait allusion à notre attitude quant à
la grève dans les ptt ou vous n'avez pas
été très favorable
vous savez on ne peut pas empêcher les
gens de parler par complet il faut
donner à tous à l'importance que ça ait
pas plus que la fédération cfdt soit
mécontente parce que notre fédération
force ouvrière ne s'est pas engagée dans
la grève je peux le concevoir mais enfin
lorsque quelqu'un comme est selon nous
une erreur je ne vois pas pourquoi nous
suivrions vous habitez vous même assez
dur de lui dire c'est cette grève
générale est une opération menée par là
par le pc avec l'accord de la cgt et
puis avec le concours irresponsable la
cfdt c'est pas très gentil les seules
opinions de la fédération force ouvrière
des ptt et j'approuve totalement le
comportement de la fédération vous savez
la grève est une affaire grave
il ne faut il recourir que lorsque tous
les autres moyens d'action ont été
épuisés et puis mes amis postiers ont
également le souci du service public
c'est pas un problème mineur femmes en
politique
supposons que les deux les deux
scénarios d'abord la majorité gagne
qu'est ce que vous faites vous force
ouvrière vous continuer à réclamer cette
cinquième semaine de congés payés que
vous avez été refusée et plus que jamais
alors il y a 2 solutions ou ont négocié
avec les employeurs par voie
conventionnelle je préfère cette formule
est monsieur ceyrac n'est pas très pur
pour l'instant nous verrons après les
élections et si on ne peut pas le faire
sur le plan conventionnel alors il faut
en effet légiférer mais vous savez quel
que soit le résultat des élections
force ouvrière ne fera pas plus de
démagogie demain qu'aujourd'hui nous
nous conduirons comme maintenant en gens
responsables et si je peux exprimer une
opinion alors que cette campagne
électorale est déjà bien engagée
c'est de souhaiter que ceux qui briguent
les suffrages des électrices et des
électeurs aient conscience qu'après le
19 il y aura le vin il faut qu'on sache
que les promesses qui seront faites par
les uns ou par les autres devront être
appliquées car en effet comment les gens
comprendraient utile puisqu'on va leur
répéter jusqu au 19 tous les jours
plusieurs fois par jour on fera ceci et
on fera cela pourra donc tenir les
promesses et c'est pourquoi avant de
formuler ses promesses peut-être faut-il
bien mesurer leurs prolongements
c'est l'opinion de force ouvrière
justement sylvain de ces la gauche a
c'est le deuxième scénario
vous allez continuer à stigmatiser ces
nationalisations que vous dénonciez
comme étant début de la bureaucratie ne
stigmatisons rien du tout nous avait
fait ya quelques mois non étiez sur ce
plateau non non non je vais vous dire
nous affirmons que la question de savoir
s'il convient de nationaliser un groupe
ou un autre relève du pouvoir politique
par contre nous nous désintéressons pas
des prolongements possibles des
nationalisations et notamment des formes
de consultations auxquelles on va
convier les à travers lesquelles on va
convier les salariés à se prononcer sur
les orientations industrielles ce que
vous appelez les soviets un peu alors là
nous sommes évidemment prudents car nous
savons par expérience que des
rassemblements de cette sorte sont la
plupart du temps manipulés par des
minorités agissantes et en particulier
par les cellules communistes engagement
je remercie un mot sur cette date des
ptt dont nous parlions il y avait ce
matin une nette tendance à la reprise du
travail selon l'aministration l'activité
est redevenue normale dans les centres
de marseille montpellier nantes et
toulouse c'est dans la banlieue
parisienne que le mouvement reste le
plus suivi à 35%
enfin la télévision la grève de l'ina
l'institut national de l'audiovisuel
fait tache d'huile et syndicats de tdf
ont déposé un préavis de grève pour
après demain nous allons donc des
nouvelles des répercussions sur antenne
2 pour jeudi
et puis maintenant les entretiens franco
allemand les 31e du nom au sommet et
visiblement le 15e anniversaire du
traité signé par charles de gaulle et
konrad adenauer a été aujourd'hui
célébrer sans le moindre nuage entre
paris et bonn la coopération et la
concertation franco-allemandes sont
sortis renforcés du sommet de paris
bellery giscard d'estaing et helmut
schmidt ont dit oui à de nouveaux avions
commerciaux ont réaffirmé leur volonté
de poursuivre leurs efforts dans
l'espace avec le lanceur ariane ont tous
deux souligné leur préoccupation devant
la situation dans la corne de l'afrique
pas de décision spectaculaire donc mais
la confirmation d'un excellent climat
pour le 15e anniversaire du traité
franco allemand
cette rencontre est très importante ici
parce que c'est vous le savez le 15e
anniversaire du traité qui a fondé
l'entente et la coopération entre la
république fédérale d'allemagne et la
france et ce traité a été signé dans la
salle où nous délibérerons j'assistais à
sa signature avec d'ailleurs deux des
ministres actuels du gouvernement
monsieur peyrefitte et monsieur boulin
et je garde encore le souvenir de
l'image altière du général de gaulle et
du chancelier adenauer signant côte à
côte ce document ce document qui mettait
fin au très long contentieux historique
et souvent si cruelle entre l'allemagne
et la france et qui ouvraient une ère
nouvelle dans leurs relations
j'ai pu constater au cours de ce sommet
combien désormais est étroite
l'entente entre l'allemagne fédérale et
la france les choses n'ont pas traîné au
congo brazzaville les dix accusés
condamnés à mort hier par la cour
révolutionnaire d'exception ont été ce
matin passé par les armes et il était
accusé d'avoir comploté contre l'ancien
président habib tués au cours de la
tentative de coup d'état
remise hier soir du prix scientifique de
la fondation de france le lauréat c'est
le professeur marcel b 6 dans les
travaux ont essentiellement porté sur
l'étude des cellules du sang et pour ce
faire il a eu recours à la caméra à des
techniques qui lui ont permis de filmer
la vie la naissance à maladie et la mort
des cellules
vous allez voir l'extrait d'un de ses
films d'une très grande beauté mais
aussi disent tous les savants d'une
grande rigueur scientifique
regardons ça un globule rouge du sang
humain
un coup de laser il éclate et son
contenu se répand dans le milieu un
laser pour détruire une caméra pour
observer il n'en faut ni plus ni moins
pour être à la fois biologiste pédagogue
et artistes
dans une goutte de sang diluer le laser
provoque la mort d'une cellule attirés
par les messages chimiques que dégage le
récent cadavres des globules blancs se
précipitent ils eux d'épaisses il le
dévore comme des requins même chose en
accéléré cette fois
tous les jours des milliers de nos
cellules disparaissent sans doute comme
celle ci pendant longtemps on n'a pas
voulu le croire
caméras et laser ont permis de le
démontrer comme chez les requins l'odeur
de la mort transforme de paisibles
globules blancs en nettoyeur sans merci
mais la logique de la vie veut aussi que
le mangeur puisse être mangé un éclair
du travail au lait et c'est le globule
blanc qui trinquent cette fois il enfle
ils gonflent
il éclate et aussitôt attire les autres
regardez la curée cela n'est qu'une
expérience pour la caméra mais c'est
aussi résumée en quelques images
l'étonnante lutte pour l'existence de
tous les jours au sein même de notre
corps un peu de sport maintenant et du
football l'équipe de france est en effet
la veille d'un grand match retransmis en
direct par antenne de demain à 15 heures
le choc contre l'italie l'italie qu'elle
affrontera vous savez dans les poules
éliminatoires en argentine pour la coupe
du monde
un match pour rien donc parce qu amical
mais un match que ne bouderont pas les
tifosi italiens
le stade sera plein à craquer à nabeul
c'est sûr 80000 napolitains vont remplir
le stade san paolo
d'abord parce qu'on aime le football
mais aussi parce que la france a une
excellente réputation ni tél
depuis que lens a battu la lazio de rome
et depuis que bastia a battu le torino
de turin vous savez que la france n'a
pas réussi à battre l'italie depuis plus
de 50 ans alors d'après vous qu'est ce
qui va se passer mercredi que mercredi
je pense que la phase de gagner mais le
perdra pas match nul
cette fois mais avec les 80 milles
napolitains qui vont soutenir l'équipe
d'italie quand même la france est en
position de faiblesse maintenant je
pense pas que
parce que je crois que le public sera
important oui mais mais l'équipe
italienne est pas en forme à ce moment
là c'est vrai que l'équipe d'italie
n'est pas en forme
le match nul serait tout à fait justifié
et même bienvenu à naples quitte à
décevoir les tifosi qui se réunissent
tous les soirs dans la galerie sainte
car 3 0 pour l'italie
allons allons pas d'excès tout de même
verra bien rendez vous donc demain à 15h
sur antenne 2 on verra bien qui sera le
meilleur
alors le temps demain il restera
médiocre sur l'ensemble du pays seul le
sud-est bénéficiera d'un petit peu de
soleil avec des vents assez forts dans
le midi dans le nord-est et bien le
temps sera plus frais avec des gelées ou
de la neige ailleurs dit on est bien
alternance de nuages et de pluie
dany journal vous sera présenté vers
23h30 par gérard holtz
mais celui ci n'est pas tout à fait
terminé j'en ai fait un cadeau pour vous
le retour de barbara le retour de la
longue dame brune
après quatre ans d'absence sur une scène
parisienne elle a donné hier à l'olympia
sa première publique devant une salle
enthousiaste 25 minutes de rappels pour
saluer son tour de chant et le record
sera peut être battu ce soir barbara n'a
pas accordé lyn thériault depuis trois
ans pour georges big mountain 2
la voici en exclusivité la laisse
écouter et je vous dit bonsoir à tous
pour moi c'était très important je
passais mon temps c'était très émouvant
de revenir c'est vraiment un rendez vous
d'un mot mais devant tant d'amour encore
devant alors je sais pas parce qu'on
vient tout petit petit
j'avoue fermeté les adieux vous avait
déjà montré là dessus je dis que je
prenais jamais ces vases ou jamais c'est
ce que c'est ce que tu plus ou moins ce
que la presse a dit mais moi je ne
jamais paraître j'ai dit que je prenais
des distances et j'ai pris des distances
parce que cet amour là mais était très
importante elle ment important m'importe
c'est tellement que je n'ai pas de
fonction mais je prie après new zealand
l'absence on peut s'attendre
donc là j'ai pas de sens sans nouvelles
s'est pas tout à fait le cas mais je
pense car parce que j'ai pas écrit et en
fait je sais pas si c'est important de
venir s'il faut absolument être nouveau
offert deux heures en tout cas en ce qui
me concerne j'ai pas écrit donc j'ai pas
fait semblant décrire ce que j'ai pas pu
écrire
et justement ce qui est fantastique
c'est que c'est bon j'ai l'impression
que mes chansons n'ont pas sans
nouvelles mais que je les chante pour la
première fois ça c'est vrai et ce qui
est fou c'est que il n'attend pas
chansons nouvelles finalement c'est ça
qui est inexplicable parce que je
comprends pas ça très bien
de fait l'om mordait l'on vous montre ma
vie j'ai plus loin du premier rang
enfin deux premiers repères lors j'avais
15 ans je retrouve blanc et gasset
faisons l'amour
ce fut j'ai des fréquences de temps d'un
saumon comme les morsures d'un amour ou
plus loin qu'il m'en souviens si depuis
j'ai lu je t'aime ma plus belle histoire
d'amour
souvent c'est vrai je pense
j'ai topé bien dépeint pour l'élire
valangin depuis rien
c'est vrai je ne fus pas un jeu aimé
gagner demain
déjà disparu
mais à travers le réseau ctv vous déjà
le coeur est nu
je refuse de bonnes
mais pour suivre mon virage le belle
histoire de mots
sur la longueur tu me l'as vers vous
sur la longueur où j'allais
le vent de décembre fall est au bout
mais force est de 100
si c'était pour le fus qui fait l'info
mais je me laissais ma vie l'aladi
jusqu'à peu
je ne suis pas par jour si ce soit pour
vous un jeunot il en eût fallu bien
d'autres tous quelqu'un vendait sa peau
univers où la neige à montaut pour ce
que je faisais passer et j'ai calmé
violents de l'histoire
en hiver et d'automne de nuit le jour
métier jamais son vin
elle vous perdant soudain
j'avais besoin de que dix ans veut nous
en montre monte ouvert leur banc vert
heureusement les loin de oui je vous
faisais fidèles quand même plus belle
histoire d'amour
je pleurais maintenant
film à feu doux ce premier sourire de
pour une lentille venu